[Música]
soy del municipio san pedro de buena
vista provincia charcas potosí de una
comunidad rural es que en cachi desde
pequeña crecí en una comunidad rural una
familia prohombres soy la última de
todos aquellos
obviamente todos los marchistas
hasta mi mamá entonces desde pequeña
estoy en una una de educativas rural
también que hasta los 90
añadía los unidades educativas hasta
quinto básico así lo llamábamos
este día y después tenía que dejar
obligadamente porque ya no había donde
estudias
muchos entre vídeos tenía que romper
muchas barreras uno es que decir de la
gente por qué
casi pocas de tanto sombras en la
escuela he sido las únicas tal vez
pero entre tantos
otra barrera en la familia también
tenía que cuidar mis animales la vall
para mis hermanos por hombres como la
última
especial ayudar en la cocina cocinar
para mis hermanos
es un pez
posteriormente decido depende
porque he querido ser algo más en la
vida
entonces dije yo quiero estudiar
mi mamá no que va a mirar de sobras que
en el campo dos lógicas generales los
animales
y va a ayudar a lavar cocinar lo típico
entonces a mis 11 12 años yo decidí ir a
capacitar un poquito más muy niña
todavía
y mi cuñado y ahora catequista de los
misioneros claretianos en san pedro de
buena vista que en esta el norte de
potosí también
entonces fui sin pregunta tal vez a mi
familia con él
también 20 personas más de 20 personas
por los hombres la única mujer que iba
caminando 8 a 10 horas
querer capacitarse será algo más en la
vida
entremedio en la capacitación he sido
una de esas niñas que decían qué
significa esa palabra qué significa esto
porque lengua materna escucha yo no
hablaba ni una sola palabra
entonces dije qué significa
y pasaron años a mis 17 años conseguí
una beca completa para estudiar mi gran
anhelo para hacer algo en la vida por lo
menos mi sueño tal vez se cumpliría en
nuestro entonces
y completando con esta beca para ir a
estudiar yo sí tenía que avisar a mis
padres entonces decidí no avisar todo
ante durante todo año
y ese año pasó llega un día faltando un
día como mañana tenía que irme a
estudiar dije a mi mamá
tengo esto quiero
y mi mamá dijo que era el papá y tres
ovejas nuevamente con eso entonces el
paso sería al día siguiente en el campo
nos levantamos trece y media y cuatro de
la mañana y estoy
expectativa qué dirán mis padres
entonces
dijeron mi mamá a las 4 de la mañana se
levanta y estoy escuchando pero
simulando que estoy durmiendo entonces
dijo su hija queréis mi papá dijo
discutieron primero y después dijo que
vaya
entonces a las 8 de la mañana ya después
de comer porque en el campo no hay
desayuno directamente la comida entonces
comemos en mi preparación de alto vamos
a hablar contigo
que tienes que ir tienes esto
sí
lo primero dije no te voy a hacer gastar
tu plata no te voy a pedir planta para
mi sopa para
para los para todas las cosas que se
necesitan yo me las arreglo y me fui
porque me venían a recoger los
claretianos una movilidad entonces ha
sido un cambio tremendo salir de mi casa
de una comunidad rural aún a un
internado de monjas como este lugar
primero me gusta cómo ha sido mi idioma
yo no sabía hablar lo otro
el ambiente totalmente diferente muy
diferente tenía que aprender nuevas
reglas hasta del tendido de la cama
y hasta lo posterior cinco años allá
porque no quería venir de vacaciones
porque mi mamá me decía ya no vayas
hijita
estoy sufriendo estos animales
nuevamente
entonces
[Música]
estuve 5 años
creo que por eso digo yo que las mujeres
somos más machistas que los hombres
hay un dicho si educas a un hombre
solamente está acercando a un su nombre
y ser en casa una mujer está educando
toda una familia
entonces
[Aplausos]
205 años regresé directamente a hacer un
trabajo con los jóvenes adolescentes y
me especial entonces ahí dije
tenemos hemos tenido muchos problemas en
un internado también en el cual he
decido
responsable de estos niños más de más de
140 personas entre mujeres y hombres
entonces
dije estos problemas dónde está el error
donde hemos cometido este error entonces
llegué
buscando buscando llegue que el error
está en la familia no está en el hombre
no está en la mujer sino en la familia
porque en la familia no sólo vivimos
madre e hija si no estamos papá a los
hermanos y todos creo que debemos
apoyarnos todos somos corresponsables
pequeños
entonces formé
entre padres de familia escuela de
padres de familia donde tenían que venir
papá mamá los dos porque la educación
empieza desde el hogar
pasamos eso y un momento dado me
proponen hacer autoridades del municipio
una mujer en poder de decisión y tenía
que decidir el destino débil de 30 mil
dos habitantes en el municipio san pedro
de buena vista y ha sido un duro momento
de poder asumir estar
este sitio
porque al final primero inicialmente
esas eran las únicas de las mujeres que
me enfrentaba decía yo tengo decir lo
que yo siento en lo que yo pienso había
uno de mis compañeros que me decía
y ustedes mujeres tú tienes que decir
apoyar y votar por lo que estoy diciendo
y yo
yo decidí acompañar yo pienso
yo también siento
no lo voy a apoyar
por qué indecisión
yo lo hago y yo decido a mi manera
de acuerdo a las cosas que están
haciéndose correctamente
hay muchas cosas entonces en ese ente
será autoridad hemos tenido muchas
peleas
y compañeros dirigentes del que
desciende mío
yo soy igual es amiga de los hombres que
las mujeres entonces muchas veces como
todos nosotros nos vamos acompañados de
alguien allá o aquí sea un amigo un
primo compañero pero la gente diciendo
la sabe está comer
ya se han metido con él
una lección más aprendida de que las
mujeres son los tipos de activas y una
una equivocación es un delito para la
sociedad
es un delito
en las mujeres entre mujeres somos bien
envidiosos
no nos apoyamos entre mujeres y eso es
lo que ha pasado
a pesar de todo
forme centro piloto de mujeres en unas
opciones al municipio san pedro de buena
vista donde las mujeres tenemos que
prepararnos
donde las mujeres tenemos que ocupar
algunos sitios no será el cien por cien
porque estamos transición todavía
lo importante primero extender nuestra
autoestima
seamos profesionales seamos del área
urbana rural seamos donde estemos donde
estemos pues tenemos que querernos a
nosotros mismos así como somos así que
como me ven cómo se ven ustedes no
tenemos vergüenza de nosotros mismos
lo importante
lo otro
nuestra valentía de ser mujer
porque ser valientes
nos llaman a cumplir nuestros sueños y
si no somos estamos perdidos
y lo más importante como mujeres debemos
prepararnos
para nuestros propensos a creer lo que
dicen
y es como mi compañero me vas a apoyar
lo que yo diga
si no estamos preparados estamos
perdidos y sobre todo
perder el miedo
el miedo es el asesino de todos nuestros
sueños
y es el traicionero como dicen entonces
creo es el septo como todas las mujeres
debemos cumplir así crecer en nuestra
familia pero sobre todo personalmente
muchas gracias
[Música]